you doing okay
i frightened you a little bit hanging in
there i came in to see you uh before the
show and you were and we've met a bunch
of times you've been on the show you
were freaked out by my height
and you acted like i was a monster or
something i came in just to say hi and
you practically started screaming i
think i'm just overwhelmed with how
how incredibly handsome you are in
person yes
that's
wait wait wait wait
wait
every day that's so every day that's so
sad that nobody bought that uh i just
have to i have to avert my gaze
i understand everyone in the crowd was
like uh yeah
no i mean it seems frightening to me
it's the
redheads are rare
yes and getting rarer all the time
exactly there's gonna be none in ten
years apparently that's what i heard
what are you i'm like what are you
talking about um no it means we're going
to go extinct eventually but 10 years
makes it sound like i'm a ticking time
bomb you would probably die within 10
years yeah thanks a lot pal the wrong
information sorry i don't want to know
about that
let me ask you about this last time
you're on the show we got on this weird
conversational jag which i didn't expect
we started talking about your hobby
which is
taxidermy collection you like to collect
taxidermy
dead animals we all know what taxidermy
is it's a
lot easier
a lot easier than having real animals um
especially when you live in a city
i it's actually illegal to um to have
horses in certain zones and and
really expensive right live horses yeah
so i get fake ones well not fake ones
but i get dead ones you got ones
that are dead and stuffed
yeah yeah and and and and so this is
they're easier to care for you don't
have to feed them obviously yeah and you
don't have to so this is something that
you got started doing and i'm just
curious like do you have what are the
newest animals that you have do you buy
new ones since uh since conan
the uh the raccoon that you so um
you so uh you so generously gifted to me
we gave you a raccoon last time you were
here a dead raccoon i uh that's the kind
that's the kind of show we run here
you get a big star on you find out they
have an interest and you give them a
dead raccoon well listen i think it's um
it's definitely special shoddy
craftsmanship but um
he's still there he's still there i
don't know i did that myself
i did it in a hurry
you know yeah i really appreciated it
but he's got new friends now um named
kevin sparkle and she dynasty and they
are um um a fox
uh a goat
and uh like a hybrid taxidermy um
embroidered deer
hybrid taxidermy sounds like it's half
alive no it's not it's like kill me kill
me
kill me
it's horrible
what a great premise great premise for a
movie um
no if i i do have dreams that they come
alive and talk to me but i mean they
don't
they don't do that
they're dead so what does this say about
you do you think have you thought about
it at all that you have all of these
taxidermied animals around your house
they give you bad dreams and yet you
continue to have them what does this say
there's an energy that you walk into
when you walk into your house there's
just these animals staring at you
i guess maybe maybe i just need someone
to care about me and i just kind of
project to my skin that is the saddest
thing i've ever heard
you care about me don't you oscillate
[Laughter]
you yes what i mean
sorry
i went to another place i went to
another place this is a photograph of
you at home relaxing with your with your
dear pals it does really look like
they're interested in what you're
reading i know
we staged it that's nice